but today
let's step things up a bit now shall we
because today we're talking about no
mere mortals here in this video we're
counting down some of the most
overpowered god characters in anime
literal gods mind you not just
overpowered guys who get tagged gods as
a meme
trust me there are loads of them and
here are some of my favorites that i'd
like to share with you
but before we move on i'd like to thank
today's sponsors
gemstone legends if you're someone who
craves for those good old match 3 puzzle
games
here's a free-to-play game that ought to
satisfy all of those cravings
gemstone legends is a very fun mobile
puzzle rpg with a modernized twist
it's more than just a puzzle game this
is a game that brings you the best of
both worlds
as it plays both as a strategy game and
a call back to the old school rpgs of
your childhood years
as you can see the game's big selling
point for me is just how much of an rpg
it is
you can choose your favorite heroes from
the main clans available and learn the
play styles associated with them the
heroes can be upgraded all the way to
six stars
and each one comes with his or her own
perks it's a mastery of the heroes and
the various dragons available that will
pave the way to victory
yes there are dragons in this game too
the dragons are there to support you and
provide various buffs
opening the waves to even more dynamic
strategies for all players
in contrast to some of the puzzle games
like this gemstone legends has a very
strong multiplayer integration
you and your opponent use the same board
and it's up to your strategies and
masterful usage of the special abilities
at your disposal to make you come out on
top the multiplayer integration doesn't
stop there do you know that you can also
form guilds with other players
team up with the greatest teammates and
defeat those mighty raid bosses
such an interesting twist on a beloved
genre right download gemstone legends
from the link in the description
enter promo code vinnie hashtag in the
game chat within three hours for
additional rewards
take hold of your destiny and become the
greatest hero in the world
now without further ado let's get
started with the list starting off we
have everyone's favorite five penny god
yato
[Music]
foreign
now this is a rather tame opening while
i wouldn't personally consider yato the
definition of overpowered
i think that he's got more in the tank
than that conceited and easy-going
attitude might suggest
yeah he seems out of shape now in terms
of being overpowered but yato himself
has more than enough experience in the
field of combat
once a god of calamity yato has since
retired from such a fearsome reputation
he may seem washed up now and compared
to his previous incarnation he sure is
however he's nowhere near weak he's far
from it in fact he's also pretty cool
for being a master swordsman something
that you don't immediately associate
with a god character
he fights with his trusty sword in his
signature move rend that allows him to
sever spiritual connections
a master of magic and physical combat
yato i feel definitely belongs in this
[Applause]
[Music]
list
let's continue with the bang now shall
we and by bang i mean one with the
roaring clap of thunder as nl storms his
way into the list
the ruler of skypier and the main
antagonist of that arc
nl can fool a lot with his lanky build
it takes a lot to be the ruler of
skypier right but i won't be surprised
if he didn't stick out as a god but boy
is he one overpowered being who deserves
every bit of the god label he certainly
thinks so too
and his hauntiness knows no bounds he
then backs that up with immense physical
strength and earth-shattering lightning
powers thanks to his devil fruit
overall i think the nl is quite the
overpowered god alright
luffy just had a good match up but he's
a lot stronger than he may seem
coming up next is jin maury
is this a spoiler i mean i guess so but
i don't think random anime fans are
still scrambling to watch god of high
school these days and i think the most
existing fans already know some cool
trivia about the show
such as jin mori's true identity then
again given what he showcased in the
anime i think that anything less than a
god just wouldn't make sense now would
it let's see besides his unique
techniques
gina showed off physical abilities that
are just beyond human just look at his
strength
speed and endurance those don't seem
normal and that's saying a lot
considering how crazy the power scaling
in god of high school can get
wants him take those powers up to 11
when he finally transforms and shows us
his true form
[Music]
garguya comes in as the next god on the
list
yes i'm aware that i spent a lot of time
on the recent list talking about mother
hey with how overpowered he is i think
that mother deserves to be auto included
in some of these
but today we'll talk about the one
character who one-ups him and takes his
place as the actual final villain of
naruto
to be fair kaguya does have the pedigree
to be the final villain
after all this godlike being is the
originator of chakra on earth
oh and like a certain god that we'll be
talking about very soon
gaguya is a mother of a powerful being
in this case
hangaromo the sage of the six paths and
she shows off her metal in the final
battle
giving team seven all they can handle
before finally being defeated
she may not have as much screen time as
mother but she's definitely on par with
him in terms of combat strength the
anime also does a nice thing of adding
more gagula backstory compared to the
manga
so if you're interested in knowing more
about her go for the anime instead of
the manga
the ahmad has terrorized the world in
the past and she's come back to do so
once again
fate grand orders babylonia arc's
ultimate villain is none other than
diamond for those who know the ancient
mythology
we really mean the primordial goddess of
the seas and the mother of all
subsequent gods
it's that theomath who's been teased
ever since the start of the babylonia
arc
and she soon emerges to show us the
destruction and horror that only an
angry god can bring tanking noble
phantasms left and right diamond just
provides the perfect challenges for our
heroes who spent
episodes on and desperately buying time
even when their mother was weakened
enough to be in a position to be beaten
they still barely pulled through in a
win that can be called a fluke
and that's due to so much help from all
sorts of allies diamond does serve as
the perfect final boss before the end of
fate grand order's epic story
the first part at least
we move on to the next god on the list
now eisen
aizen is a cool example because we get
to see his development from powerful
shinigami to godhood in the bleach anime
i know there's a joke going around that
eisen's the real main character of
bleach
but with the focus given on him and his
journey is that really big of a joke he
sure lived up to the billing he's
practically become invincible
and not even ichigo's strongest moves
can finish him off despite him taking
l after l in that battle he's so
powerful
that he can only be sealed with the new
bleach anime looming on the horizon will
we get to see aizen unleashed once more
tune in to find out
[Applause]
with a list of villains and overpowered
protagonists we've showcased so far
madoka may seem to be a step down but
don't underestimate her by appearance
alone if you thought the izen had a big
leap into godhood
what more for madoka who went from a
completely ordinary and helpless girl
to ascending to another plane and pretty
much becoming a concept
in contrast to aizen who felt like a
main character despite not being one
madoka was the opposite she's the
titular girl who gets shown in all those
magical girl outfits in the opening but
the plot rarely revolves around her it
seems
still it was her transcendental wish
that finally put an end to the
unstoppable walpurgis night and saving
the world
both the past and the future oh and the
original episode of her ascension to
godhood aired right around the catholic
holy week so while coincidental
is still quite an amusing piece of
trivia to have
[Music]
next we go back to high school with
harui suzumiya once again we go from
godly overpower to whimsical still
there's little denying the charisma of
one of the most influential characters
in the 2000s the leader of the sos
brigade gets placed this high on the
list simply
due to legacy or is it i mean harui's a
reality warper
and that's probably as broken and
overpowered as gods can get right among
the gods here that mostly aim to wow us
with their
power and feet harui feels more down to
earth in perspective
kind of like madoka except very very
eccentric and proactive with whatever
craziness she has in her mind
poor kion right her adventures with the
sos brigade have caught the hearts of
more than its fair share of anime fans
back in the day
and some veterans still fondly look back
to those old days
[Music]
it's been so long since i've heard of
anyone mentioning tenchi muyo so i don't
blame anyone for not knowing who
gamitenchi is
for those who haven't watched it i guess
this also acts as a recommendation of
sorts if you enjoy watching god
characters in action it's quite a hot
debate before about gami denshi being
the most powerful character in anime
all of anime so that includes the likes
of other universes
that can be debated and if those of you
who've watched tenshi muyo agree or
disagree with this
let me know in the comments below
whatever the answer to that is there's
no question that kami denshi is the
pinnacle of power in the tenshi muyo
universe
lighthawks wings creations anyone he
also effortlessly stopped the
incarnation of the world's forces to
counteract the other gods by himself
definitely a candidate for most broken
character in all of anime
finally we finish this with a bang as we
take a look at zeno from dragon ball
super
[Applause]
is it really a surprise that we end with
a dragon ball character how could we
talk about a list of my favorite gods
without going through the entire roster
of overpowered beasts that the dragon
ball universe has
somewhere in the animate featuring goku
and his simply broken piers is this
unassuming guy you're telling me that
this is the ruler of the multiverse
appearances can be deceiving as if that
list hasn't already driven that point
home yet yes zeno is indeed the
strongest being in the universe the
strongest being in the universe of a
series full of explosions and fireworks
and well-shattering fights
is a being who doesn't fight however
zeno possesses a far more devastating
ability than the best fighting skills or
the most destructive techniques known in
the world and that's the ability to just
erase things out of existence
universes have outright been erased due
to zeno's abilities and it's accurate to
say that the ability has the highest
kill count in the series
ten gods above them all that more or
less wraps up my showcase of my favorite
anime gods
now it's your turn to share your top 10
gods list and i'll be waiting
in the comments section special thanks
to zodiac 15 and all other patreons for
making this video possible don't forget
to check out our sponsors game gemstone
legends
links in the description that's gonna be
it for today i hope to see you in the
next video that i'm to upload take care
and have a good day